so oil prices aged higher today on the
prospects
for stronger global economic growth the
international monetary fund said
in its latest world economic outlook
report that
unprecedented public spending to fight
kovit 19 would push global growth to 6
this year a rate not seen since the
1970s
but the rebound will be far from even
and for some
there might be permanent scarring let's
take a look
if all goes according to plan it would
be the fastest expansion of the global
economy since the imf started tracking
growth in 1980.
the fund says such an optimistic
forecast is only possible
thanks to a rapid fiscal response to the
pandemic
but there's no doubt some sectors have
suffered irreparable damage
now because the crisis has accelerated
the transformative forces of
digitalization and automation
many of the jobs lost are unlikely to
return requiring worker reallocation
across sectors
which unfortunately often comes with
severe earning penalties
swift policy action worldwide including
16 trillion dollars in fiscal support
prevented far worse outcomes the imf
predicts the rollout of covert 19
vaccinations
and huge sums of government aid will
trigger a powerful rebound from the
pandemic recession
but the fund's chief economist warned
the recovery would be unequal with
already poor countries falling
further behind without additional
efforts
to give all people a fair shot
cross-country gaps in living standards
could widen significantly
the imf predicts the global rebound will
gradually lose momentum
and return to pre-covered levels of just
above three percent annual growth
countries will once again have to deal
with the same obstacles they faced
before the pandemic
including aging workforces in most rich
countries
as well as in china
well despite its aging workforce there's
certainly one country that is on a rapid
expansion path and that is
china over the next five years the
world's second biggest economy is
expected to account for more than a
fifth of total global growth the us
buoyed
by a huge spending program is also
firmly on the up
emerging asian economies like india are
rising
rapidly too now europe's biggest
economies on the other hand
germany france and the united kingdom
are lagging
rather far behind in comparison so are
we seeing an ever
widening divide between asia and europe
to find out more about that
i'm joined now by nidhi rai she's a
journalist based in mumbai and
we are also joined by our financial
correspondent chelsea delaney in
frankfurt hello to both of you and i
would like to start with you needy
because
india is mentioned by the imf as one of
these strong
asian economies but where is all this
growth actually coming from
so interestingly today the rba the
reserve bank of india which is the apex
banking body in the country has also
come out with their monetary policy
review
in which uh the governor has said that
even though that the even though the
economy is facing some challenges
because of the second wave of corona
virus
still there the ruler demand is looking
very very void and the ruler demand is
looking very strong
and the agriculture output and the way
the rural market are
working they are helping the urban
market and therefore
some green shoots are coming from there
and obviously that
nobody was so nobody is uh it's too
early to comment on the fact that how
the second wave is going to impact the
economy
so primarily the rural demand is pushing
the economy and
obviously people are also keeping some
hopes high that
there will not be a complete lockdown
and the businesses will not be
completely shut
okay so this is what's happening right
now uh the forecast of course was
looking
uh at a more longer term uh to 2026 and
giving india the thumbs up there
unlike europe chelsea
when you think about it the u.s and
europe actually accounted for about
half of global growth back in the 1980s
combined they're now responsible for
about 30 percent
growth but the outlook for europe is
pretty dismal
what's going wrong
well these are changes that have been in
some to some degree expected
for decades now china taking over as the
world's largest economy that's been
expected for quite a long time and part
of this is just population trends china
has
four times the population of the united
states double that
of of europe and as china but also
economies like india
industrialize more as they get wealthier
they come to
make up a bigger part of the economy but
the pandemic has certainly
accelerated this shift in in global
power
because china has recovered so much more
quickly than
uh the rest of the world particularly
europe uh it has
it's now becoming a bigger part of the
economy it's now expected to become the
biggest economy in the world by 2028
that's about two years earlier than
previously expected
and what's this mean for europe i mean
there's this saying uh the difference
between europe and china is that china
has a plan
it's time for europe to come up with a
plan or are they happy to be dependent
on china
well europe does have a plan uh they
they've mostly put in place the 750
billion
euros stimulus package uh it's it's been
called the next generation eu fund a lot
of that money
is supposed to go towards efforts to
modernize the eu economy things like
uh climate infrastructure uh technology
building out things like a semiconductor
industry
as well as digitalization so it does
have a plan but the question is is it
too little too late this effort
even for this stimulus package has been
really beset by political differences
by the eu bureaucracy so as
china races ahead as the u.s prepares
trillions of dollars worth of stimulus
europe is still very much struggling to
get even that small amount of money
into the economy right and needy even
though uh
india is currently uh struggling with uh
this second strong wave the outlook
if we believe the imf is pretty good
with strong
strong growth um do you think i mean how
will this shape the country if this is
actually
come to fruition uh will will everybody
benefit equally or will it even widen
the gap between
the rural communities and the city elite
interestingly even though imf is excited
about the indian economy and
and imf has given a thumbs up uh
analysts economists and
people in the country are not are saying
that it's a very ambitious
task being said that the next point is
this that the
that the migrant workers have again
started going back to their
cities and to their villages the
industries have all
the hospitality industry the hotels the
restaurants the cinema halls they have
all been shut
so if there is going to be uh if there
is going to be a growth
if that growth is going to be for
everybody that's a very difficult thing
for india because
there is a huge inequality already
poverty is already a challenge
malnutrition is already a challenge here
i
what everybody thinks and i also believe
what we have seen in last one year is
this that this pandemic has
made the is this inequality gap a bit
wider
and if this keeps happening this is
going to be the biggest challenge for
the country and its economy
all right needy right there a journal is
based in mumbai
and dw's chelsea delaney in frankfurt
thank you both so much